Let'sgotoyourvoicemails.Thevoicemailnumberis2192,DavidP.theaudienceisin
03/11/20 Page15of17
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­10­commercialfree
disagreementoverBernie'schancesinthe...Stillongoingfornowdemocraticprimaryhereisone
viewerwhosaysYouwillnotstopBernie,Bernieisgettingthenomination,"TaalSAN.
You'llneverstopburningtoman,nomatterhowmuchyousupporttheestablishmentyouwould
neverstophimbackbetter,right?
Yeah,well,Isupported,Bernie.Nottheestablishment.Sothere'ssomeonewhothinksBernieisa
sinandthenHere'sJimmyfromPhillyanangryviciousTempestwhoeveryonceinawhile,
stumblesacrosssomeuncontroversialminortruth.JimmyfromPhillythanksBerniehasnoshot
whatsoever.TakealistenDarrellI'mgonnatellyouhowyourLeo'sgonnago.Andacollege
graduate,I'mnotanEconomicsmajor,likeyou,that'sit.Welovethepoorlyeducatedjustlike
DonaldTrumpwhat'sgonnahappen?There'snofiringwayonGod'sscreen.ArtsthatEeyoreboy
Berniewe'llgetnominated.Justnotgonnahappeninthescrew.Somekindofway,youknowhow
they'regonnadoit,butthey'regonnadoit.Alright,sotherearetwoconflictingviewsaboutthe
Berniecandidacy.Onecallerbelievesthere'snostoppingBernietheothercolorbelievesthere'sno
waythatBernegetsthenomination.Wewillsoonknowbythetimeyoulistentothisvoice,mail,
wemayalreadyknowtheanswertothisquestion,wehaveareallygoodbonus.Soforustodayin
Alabamaschools,thereisamajordebateoverwhetherYogashouldbepartofgymclass.
Whyisthereadebate?Ibelievethatthereasonmaynotsurpriseyou,butyoushouldbeappalledby
it.
Wewillalsotalkaboutinthemidstofeverythingthat'sgoingonrightnowwiththevirus,and
everythingelse.DonaldTrumpthinkswhatweneed,ortaxcuts,weneedtaxcuts...Whyandwhat
exactlywouldthatdo?Wewilldiscussit.AndalsoMontanaGovernorSteveBullockhas
announcedthatheisgoingtorunforsentit.Now,ifyouwatchedthepresidentialcampaign,you
mayfindthisquiteinteresting.We'vetalkedalotaboutHey,therearesomepeoplearoundwho's...
Thetimewouldbebetterspentwhoseenergywouldbebetterinvested.runningforSenate.Steve
Bullockisdoingthat,andwewilltalkaboutitontoday'sbonussogetinstantaccesstothebonusto
atjoin"patandotcomorbybecomingapatronatpaperondotcom